[Music]
hello this is an interview with the
authors of the blip paper if you haven't
seen it i've made a review video of the
paper itself be sure to check that out
the authors have seen that and are
directly able to respond to it so we all
start on an even footing it's very cool
to have the authors on and this
interview particularly was really
interesting to me i hope it is to you as
always thank you for everyone who leaves
a like who leaves a comment thanks to
all the patreons and the support i get
on on twitter and on youtube itself it's
really cool and i wish you a lot of fun
thank you hey there a quick shout out to
today's sponsor assembly ai is an ai
company that offers accurate apis for
speech to text as a developer you can
use these apis to automatically
transcribe and understand audio and
video data in just a few lines of code
assembly ai automatically converts
asynchronous and even live audio streams
into text they have so many features to
help you understand your audio data for
example summarization content moderation
topic detection and much more please
check them out using the link in the
description to let them know i sent you
now let's get on with the video
[Music]
hi everyone today i'm here with junan
lee and dongxu li who are two of the
researchers of the blip paper uh it's a
very big honor to have you here welcome
both of you thanks for having us
really happy to share our work here
yeah this this paper was really cool i
think when it came out
um everyone saw it and it generated
quite a bit of of buzz because it is a
new approach to incorporating images and
language and they can do a lot of things
at the same time
it is a big system and
um yeah i was i was super happy when i
saw it and when i write the paper i was
also pretty
pretty happy after i read the paper
which sometimes isn't the case anymore
after you read the paper
uh yeah
and
if you would if you were just to dive in
maybe if you would pitch your idea to
someone like someone comes to you in a
poster session or so uh maybe for people
who haven't seen the paper review just
extremely briefly what does your paper
say or what do you
sure propose so maybe i can take this
question uh i think uh the major point
of our paper the selling point is that
we propose a unified framework for
visual language pre-training where we
can pre-train this model
that has the capability of doing both uh
major language understanding and
visual generation so uh what
understanding means it is that it can
jointly understand the two modalities
namely
image and text and produce some kind of
multi-modal features that can be used
such as for classification tasks and
what
generation means here is that it can
generate text
based on some image input for example
for image captioning
is one of a typical generation task so i
think this is the
main idea of our our model and in terms
of the technical in terms of how do we
achieve that i think there's one big uh
point that i would like to highlight is
we do have this data set bootstrapping
uh to tackle the challenge of noisy
web training data because
existing works a lot of them pre-trained
on those data that are collected from
the image
from the web which contains the image
and all text pairs which can be noisy i
think you mentioned in the review video
uh so what we do here is that we want to
synthetically generate
captions and also to use a filter to try
to remove the noisy captions and by
doing so we can
significantly improve the quality of the
data set and i think one of the key
message we want to send in the paper is
that the quality of the data really
matters uh is as important as if not
more important than the quantity so a
lot of passwords have focused on scaling
up the model with big data
but here
we do scale up but we also focus on the
quality of the data um i want to i want
wanna dive into this uh data
bootstrapping uh right away because it
is almost it is almost a bit of an
independent thing from the system itself
right the we've long known that
we can trade off quality for quantity
but usually it is in an exponential
fashion so to get the same amount more
quality we need exponentially more
data if we want to achieve it with uh
with
less quality data um did you was this
was this which came first the idea of
building
the vision language model or the idea of
filtering or the data set because they
both play nicely into one another in
your paper
and i'm just a bit wondering how did
this come to be which came first
why why one or the other
yeah
so actually for my research
for my past papers i'll focus
some papers on this weekly supervised
learning or learning from the noisy data
so i've always been quite interested in
how do people train models with
imperfect data which is a very practical
scenario and
i think this dessert this field may
deserve more attention it's not as
popular as some of the other fields
but it's really a very practical issue
and it do exist for vision language
pre-training so actually one of my
previous paper in visual language
training
which we call it elbaf model it was
published in eurips last year
we have this kind of self-training
scheme uh where we want to clean the
noise
in the data set but it's in a relatively
uh
more simpler way than what we do here
so rather than generating synthetic
captions we were doing some
self-destination thing
so then we take it to the next step in
the brief paper where we first look at
the data set and we see a lot of noise
and here now is basically means that the
caption is not really describing the
visual content of the image it may still
be a good uh human written text right
it's not the text is grammarly wrong
it's grammarly correct
it's just that it's not aligned with the
image so what we try to solve is how do
we generate
text that are more aligned with image
such that our training can benefit uh
from this
i think uh this this left picture here
illustrates it well where it just says
from a bridge near my house right uh
which is
which is a a weird thing to put in an
alt text you would put that usually in
some sort of a social media post or so
but this is one of the examples where
the old text doesn't really describe the
image i thought i thought that was
really well were you always aware of
this weakness or
um like how do you even find out that
that is a large-scale problem
yeah so i think uh i first come find out
this problem when going through
basically some of the virginia data set
so i think what people previously used a
quite standard web data set was this
conceptual
three million
which is a relatively medium scale it's
not too small but not very huge and
there are they do exist a lot of
captions like this in that data set and
i found this problem even exaggerates as
i try to use a bigger data set for
example in this paper we use the line
lion data set which was a very newly
released data set and the noisy problem
was even more
like
happens a lot more frequent
when you try to scale up the data to
include more web images with all text
so we feel like this is something that
if we can solve it it could really
changed the
model's performance
have you seen the there's a recent paper
called something like
vision models are more robust and fair
when trained on uncurated data or
something like this so
yeah this here
you you seem to say we need better
quality data and that group is saying
essentially no our models work better
when we have
less quality but but you know we just go
out and collect data can you maybe
establish a bit of a of a connection
between the two views like where do they
how do they agree
uh yeah so i think uh
maybe there's not two different aspects
one is the quality and the other is the
diversity so i think what that paper try
to maybe claim is i i haven't read into
detail it's just my uh like uh what my
impression was that they try to claim if
you have like this huge web data set
that is more diverse maybe then your
maybe human created data set you can
bring better advantage to the model i
think that doesn't contradict with what
we say here
so actually in our experiment we show
that the diversity of captions do matter
a lot uh when we try to generate
synthetic captions we try to generate a
diverse set of captions that covers a
whole bunch of different concepts
rather than a very common and safe
description of the image
yeah i think maybe
these two approaches that
seem to me do not contradict but uh
complementary to each other
uh on one aspect when you have more data
of course you can always scale up you
the success of your data sets you are
always having more samples that give you
a better capacity for the model but on
the other side with more focus on the
quality set if you really look at the
number of images we are using here for
the pre-training compared with some of
the other works is not a lot it's not
like uh
too much to to larger skill but since
the quality of our pre-training
corpus is better we are now with a
better uh
performance so i really think the skill
and the quality they are complementary
and they do not contradict
i believe yeah
um so let's stay on this on this pre uh
sorry on the on the captioning and
filtering for just one more second uh
you first did i get this right you first
pre you first pre-train the entire model
on
on this
uncurated let's say data set and then
you use fine tuning on a human generated
captioning data set uh in order to get
these filter and captioning models
um is
so my worry there would be a little bit
exactly what we talked right now
what my filter and captioning models
learn is really dependent on
let's say let's assume the quality of
the human generated data set is good but
the diversity of it really matters right
because it sort of needs to cover all
the images that come you know from the
uncurated data set otherwise it is going
to misjudge miss filter or not being
able to caption this this data set
how do you
you know how do you control for that and
maybe you can also
comment on if i now
let's say i want to expand my data set
to areas that i know
that the human one doesn't cover what
could be a method
of you know
still going still going and and
researching on this new type of data
yeah i think that's a very good question
i think it's a valid concern that this
fine tuning maybe bias the models or set
to our certain domains and i think
uh one of the reason we achieve
performance improvement is because a lot
of these downstream tasks are similar to
the coco domain image
so i think that's that's a valid point
but in the meantime i would say that
this fine tuning doesn't destroy the
model capability to generate diverse
captions and because
the fine tuning is really a very
lightweight procedure so for pro
training we portray on this huge data
set for 220 epoch which will take a few
days or maybe even a week but it's fine
tuning we only find him for five epoch
on a very small scale cocoa data set
which can finish within a few hours so
this fine tuning would not make the
model forget about what he has
previously saw
it only slightly modified the model so
that it can generate captions that are
more like human written ones but we do
find that even after fine tuning the
model can generate captions that are not
within the vocabulary of cocoa data set
so it's not like the the finding
completely destroyed the model's
diversity uh capability uh
so that's uh your
answer to our first question and for the
second question
if someone wants to
try to
expand the model to a different domain
where there doesn't exist human
annotations
i would say first if you can collect
some
it will be good
and if you cannot maybe one solution is
there might be some similar images from
this huge web data set
that maybe you can retrieve so let's say
if you can retrieve some similar images
associated with web captions
then maybe you can slightly fine-tune
the model on those subsets so that the
model becomes slightly more biased
towards your domain and more suitable to
your dancing task
you suggest
with this drawing uh you suggest in with
this arrow right here
almost you suggest like a loop
uh like
suggesting that this could be done
multiple times right i could uh
you know go go multiple times through
this stage is this is this anything um
okay i've i've maybe not seen this in
the experiment if this is anything
you've tried or would would anything
change in the loop number two or number
three or number four like what would be
the difference i have i've already you
know there's no new data introduced
uh yeah so first of all i'll say it's
definitely possible to
do multiple rounds of iterations of this
bootstrapping and in our future work we
mentioned this as one of the future work
uh and in terms of extra knowledge like
each round of bootstrapping we can add
in new captions right so if the model
becomes better it can generate better
synthetic captions and there there might
be a diminution return if we do multiple
rounds
i would say my intuition is the first
round will probably help the most and
maybe the second the third will help
less
but unfortunately due to the time and
computation constraint we didn't really
have the resource to
produce the experiment before the paper
so that's definitely one of the future
plans that we have
yeah
um so let's shift maybe
sorry
good
um okay
this
model here is quite big
uh that's was my first impression when i
saw it there's a lot of stuff okay i
have also drawn a lot of stuff on it i'm
sorry i can make this go away um
so the model here is relatively big and
relatively you know there's there's
modules going around there's parameter
sharing going on uh what was the what
was the evolution of this model was this
is this version one that we're looking
at right here or is this like you know
version 50 after you've tried a bunch of
other things
yeah yeah uh definitely not version one
so actually this model is heavily
like inspired by our previous lbf model
uh which is an encoder only model so if
you look at the model there's not too
much difference between lbf and blip
except the fact that now we add the
generation capability to believe with
language modeling laws
so the the reason why we want to add
this is first that because the encoder
models doesn't really transfer that well
to image captioning tasks and other
generation tasks so it's better that we
can pre-train it to have this capability
that's why we add in this new decoder
module
and
then after we add in the decoder module
we thought
since we are doing multi-task learning
can we share some parameters
because
first of all it's more efficient to
share parameters and secondly
and may bring some advantage from the
multitask training
by jointly optimizing
those
fuel losses so we tried different
sharing strategy strategy first we start
with not sharing any parameters at all
and then we try to share maybe the uh
so we try to decouple maybe some the
cross attention layer or the cell
potential layer or the fifo layer then
we find that the decoupling the cell
retention layer from the encoding
decoder is a more efficient and
effective way
so
that's why we choose this
strategy but
there is a
possibility that because we are doing
this experiment on a relatively smaller
scale
per training so we're using the 40
million
images for programming but our final
model was protruding on 100 million
images so maybe the sharing strategy is
not the optimal for
if you scale up the data set so i would
imagine if you want to have the best
possible
performance you may want to scale up the
data set and try to decouple the
parameters more but that would of course
sacrifice some of the efficiencies uh
bring by the parameters sharing
yeah uh another yeah
another point i probably want to add
here is like um
this architecture is not like um
ad hoc design
because remember that one of our
starting point is to
eliminate the noise
noise levels in this pre-training data
sets so from from there
we
at one side we need to identify
what are the noisy ones right whether
the image and the caption they match
with each other and that end up with
this design of encoder model
on the other side we want even more that
when we find that the the caption does
not align well with the image itself
we don't want to simply discard the
training data point we want to generate
some useful captions surprising captions
that can further help us
so
from that i really want to say that
it's not like we want to put everything
together glue different models into a
single model to make it big it really
serves very well uh
for this caption filter algorithm
yeah and i think that kind of yeah
yeah yeah
yeah just one additional comment is that
our model is really actually not big uh
if you compare to some other models so
basically our model is a vit plus a bird
so
it's a base version of the bird so in
terms of the number of parameters i
would say it's a standard uh parameter
deep learning model uh it's not that
crazy huge uh so even we joined
in the current figure actually there is
because this parameter sharing going on
the number of parameter and the training
communication load is not that heavy
um yeah i i like the fact that this
really arises from sort of the goal of
cleaning the data set it plays
i also thought the more i read it and
the more i talked about it it became
more evident that the things really
played together nicely you use uh the
you use the contrastive loss to get the
hard negatives for the for the uh for
the
i want to say like matching matching
loss or rank or loss and then that gives
you the filter and then the the language
model here gives you the captioning um
with respect to parameter sharing
um you said okay the
the
matching head or the contrastive heads
they're not really good at captioning
themselves so we'd rather pre-train or
train a captioning or a language
generation model do you find that adding
the task of language generation also
helps the tasks that the
other models would be good at
like do you find an additional benefit
except for our model can also do
captioning do you find an additional
benefit for the already existing or the
already tackled tasks by adding let's
say the language model
yes yes we find that uh there's an
advantage bring br brought by these
language model laws
so this language model loss if you think
about this is really quite similar to
the mass energy model allows except that
now it's an auto regressive version
right so in our previous iot work and
some other papers what people already do
is this mass language modeling
to try to improve the
model's capability to understand the
text
in a more fine-grained granularity
because the image text matching and
image type contrastive learning is more
like global
matching right you are trying to match
the image and text but the language
model is more fine-grained you want to
generate the word based on the image and
by
achieving so you need to better
understand maybe some details of the
image and align it with the textual
concept to be able to generate the word
um do you do you
have
let's say
more
more extensive goals in mind here you
just said it's actually not that big you
know if it's really nicely i agree with
all of that yet i foresee a future where
you could you know bring together lots
of these modules essentially what i what
i'd like to have is
um first of all we could obviously think
of doing the same with the image side
right here you just have an encoder here
right now
but we could think of you know breaking
out here doing image generation doing
um
you know what whatever we can do with
images uh but on the other hand
maybe an even bigger future vision would
be uh i bring a data set and i say look
these are pairs of images and text
now please
system make me a model that includes
all of these losses that i can think of
like all of these different combinations
and the system would figure out okay i
can share you know i can share
parameters here and i can build that and
so on and um maybe that would
given your findings which i you know i
totally believe that adding
more of these tasks and sharing the
parameters actually mutually benefits
each other the representations they
become more capable they become
maybe more more broadly meaningful and
so on so i think that might be a cool
a cool future
to to work uh against i don't know how
feasible it is though is that anything
on your roadmap or uh you know what does
the future look like of these models
yeah i think that's a very cool idea uh
maybe a very ambitious goal uh
so we have considered to id in some
image generation capability
but uh we didn't because it
doesn't fit very well with our current
framework so we don't want to make the
framework to be very huge
and messy we try to keep it more cleaner
but
regarding your point that can we have
automatic system that can maybe combine
different modules and losses
i think that's a possible
goal
it's just there could be a lot of
obstacles in how to achieve that
for example if we borrow some idea from
the nas community and maybe we borrow
some reinforcement learning idea
maybe there are some ways we can train a
policy to do that
but it's not entirely clear to me how
how can i achieve that because i think
the main problem is this for training
is uh how to evaluate the per training
is a big problem right so
you cannot just say that a
lower progenitor loss means that your
model is better downstream tasks
if if if there is uh if there is a
correlation between pretending laws and
downstream tasks
then it may be easier right you just
find the optimal module that you can
minimize your opportunity loss but
usually it's not the case it also
depends on how well aligned these
opportunities and adoption has
i think that's one of the major issues
of
why it may take some trial and error to
find the best strategy
for the purchasing
yeah maybe i can add a few sentences to
to that
um i think
being able to
figure out how to
uh you know combine these different
modules together automatically would be
super cool and futuristic
yet i think there are a couple of
practical messages that we want to
convey here uh which is a
the first i think if you really look at
how this uh we we fine-tune
we function with mbd model
to make them a a captioner a filter and
also how we combine these different
modules together
in order to tackle the downstream tasks
there are really some dedicated ways to
do that and usually if you look at
some pre-training works on the market
their strategies will be pretty
uh simplistic in the sense that in most
of occasions they just add the tasks
specific cuts but in this
particular work we
just move one step further than that we
rethinking how to rearrange these
modules and what are the best strategies
for this parameter sharing strategy um
i i hope another
message we we may want to say here is a
lot of people they blindly do this
multitasking by aggregating hundreds of
different datasets and tasks into one
training model and maybe uh from
uh from maybe uh by bleep we
want people to kind of revisit this
decision next time we do this they do
this multitasking because not
necessarily every task they complement
with each other and you may want to
carefully look into what to share what
not to share i think these are the two
uh things we want to uh uh remind uh
yeah for future works
yeah and i have one uh additional
comment to follow what don't you said is
that uh you can see a lot of other works
they really combine
already like maybe eight or ten
objectives together right so there are
some uh strategies for visual knowledge
training is you bring in object
detection objective to improve your
localization capability uh so we think
that's a
way to that's a valid way to improve
performance but here what we try to say
is that we want to keep things very nice
and simple right so we have these three
laws where each law serves a very clear
purpose
uh and can be transferred to a very
specific function task and all we need
is just image text pairs we don't need
any bounding box or anything else uh so
i think that's one of the message we
want to also convey
cool and yeah and and i especially i
like the fact that with pre-training
with the aspect of fine tuning then
you're able to recombine these different
modules in in very
creative ways so even even though you
have these modules they have their
purposes for the pre-training for the
captioning for the filtering but then
they can be it seems it seems uh
many many tasks can now be tackled by
some sort of combination of these models
and a little bit of fine-tuning which is
something that i find
really cool um
you have done extensive and like uh
there are there are lots of lots of
tables means you had to run like and
collect lots of numbers um which is
is very nice because it gives a bit also
of a broad overview than just having you
know four numbers or so comparing with
one baseline um although could you
and maybe highlight some of the
of the standing out results that you got
or one of some of the more important
results like how would you summarize or
what would you highlight about your
experimental evaluation of this
yeah sure i think the most important one
will be table one
uh where we demonstrate the
performance gain
achieved by how do we bootstrap our data
set
yeah and yeah so this is table basically
if you look at the first column it shows
how many images you are using so we have
two settings one is the 40 milli images
another we scale up with small noisy
image text pairs
and the second column is how do we
perform the bootstrapping
c stands for captioning and f stands for
filtering it means whether we do
captioning to generate synthetic
captions or we do filtering to remove
the noise captions or we do both
together
so if you look at the first row second
row third and the first row you can see
that
both the captioning and the filtering
can help
individually
and if you combine them together they
really help complement each other right
so by generating synthetic options and
at the same time try to remove the noise
uh we can actually i would say a quite
good amount of uh gain in this two
different uh four different uh data sets
covering both the retrieval tasks and
the captioning tasks so i think that's
one of the
key uh results we have here
and also maybe then it goes to the
second table is how do we do the
uh bootstrapping of the captchas right
so do we use bim search
or do we use nuclear sampling so the
difference between those two approaches
that beam search is a deterministic uh
sampling uh not something dependent
decoding strategy where you try to find
the most likely sentence
associated with the image and nuclear
sampling is a stochastic approach where
you try to sample according to some
probability distribution
and we find like surprisingly uh
if you compare bim search with no uh
generation there is a good gain uh
achieved by bim search but by moving bim
search to nuclear sampling there is a
similar amount of gain
so this is something that we didn't
expect at the first time we see the
results and after we really take a deep
dive into what the captions look like uh
how uh how does beam search and nuclear
something generate different captions we
found out that
the bim search will generate a kind of a
safe caption that accurately describe
the image most of the time
but it's not surprising so you can
commonly see those
the descriptions in the data set
and that doesn't add a lot of extra
knowledge for the model to learn but the
nuclear sampling really introduced some
really diverse captions
that are more like human written ones
right human don't write a very boring
distribution like a man is with a dog in
a park right so it's a very boring
boring caption but nuclear something can
give you more diverse captions and if
you look at the noise ratio which is
actually how much of those captions were
filtered out by our filter you can also
see that bim search is less noisy but
even though it's that's noisy it's not
as beneficial as nuclear sampling here
and this really raises another question
which which i think is a very
interesting future work is that is
nuclear something in the best way right
so because those models are pre-trained
with the language modeling
laws which is kind of deterministic loss
you try to maximize the likelihood
of your captions
and
we are just doing that and we try to do
something in the decoding side to try to
give more diverse captions
but this nuclear sampling was used in
mostly nlp
uh papers so is does there exist some
better diverse captioning strategy
for image captioning tasks so i think
that's a very interesting
question
i think in in recent times this has been
shining through in a lot of works
that the fact that
maybe we don't need to go
maximum likelihood in in our on our
inference step but maybe it's a better
approach to do go diverse with the
sampling and then exactly what you do
have some sort of a classifier or some
sort of a filter
to just to just scrap out the noise i
think that's a really really good
approach and we saw this you know
anywhere i think dolly
famously
had had clip re-ranking all the outputs
and i think more and more models go
towards this it's really cool really
cool finding
that you're essentially
you're finding exactly the same thing
uh when i look at these numbers um all
of the numbers it is very
it's very convincing to see that
everything uniformly almost almost
uniformly gets better right um you know
you're you support whatever you say
really well i mean this this trend right
here it's it really works across
let's say across all of the data sets
you uniformly almost get better um in
all the tables
uh however the difference is always you
know there is the maximum difference is
whatever this this from here to here is
like two points in
uh what what is this what's tr it's the
truth uh it's a
recall text record ah text retext recall
sorry oh yeah it's down here okay uh
text recall image recall um
that's like two percent right here again
it's like one point something percent so
there's a uniformly getting better uh my
question is
given that the getting better is
convincing but the scale of it is like
yeah two percent or so
when is it worth
to do this weeks long or week-long
pre-training you mentioned right this is
a big procedure the pre-training is big
and then the fine-tuning again
pre-training again
um
when is it worth it from what scale or
for what applications does it become
actually worth to do something like this
yeah i think that's a very good question
and uh
first of all i would say it is worth
doing if your data is really
uh if you observe a large amount of
noise in the data
and maybe your data is incomplete in
some of the domains for example here
the web data is primarily dominated by
those
all text which
can be different from what humans would
write to describe an image right so
there if there is a noisy scenario or
domain gap i think it's worth to do so
and secondly actually we have also
released our
data set after bootstrapping so that if
you are just trying to do regional
report training in a similar domain
i think
you can just download our version and
use that as a starting point to avoid
the first round of pre-training
and maybe certainly
about your previous comment that we have
a really unanimous improvement for those
tasks
actually in one of the tasks
maybe you can scroll down the paper
let me try to find
i think it's what the nlvr task
table 8 maybe
yeah yeah table 8. yeah actually for
this task right this is where
we find the better quality
of captions uh doesn't
necessarily give you a better
gain
if you compare
here
and actually by scaling up the number of
training image it
doesn't correlate
very straightforwardly to a downstream
performance screen
so i think it still depends on your
alignment between our training and their
downstream objective so for most of
tasks it is well aligned and that's why
improving our personal data quality can
improve your downstream tasks
yeah maybe i can either few sentences to
in terms of whether it is worthwhile to
improve that much i think if you really
imagine the big picture here
in terms of the multi-modal retrieval
let's say
if you
deploy this retrieval and that managed
to improve their profit by one percent
that's a huge achievement
and you want a lot
so
at salesforce we also have uh
the retrieval uh we have we also work
with clients for their uh retrieval uh
services so in terms of that if you just
let your gpu run for one week and
improve by one person that's a huge
improvement i would say
right and
i also
like to say that these numbers they uh
kind of
um i think uh
under hype uh what bleep has achieved uh
because i think beyond this
relative advantage uh over its
competitors
it's also qualitatively better in terms
of in terms in terms of how easy
it is to use flip if you really look at
the
demo we created there on the web whole
host on the web and
it is freely ask any questions in
natural language rather easily
in contrast a lot of this
image question answering
models they are kind of they are not
doing the freeform generation right the
kind of doing classification in order to
tackle this question answering uh tasks
this point is however not fully
demonstrated
in i believe um in in the current
manuscript so uh if you really want to
get impressed we really suggest you
check out our demo and put whatever
photos you like and questions
cool uh it's really neat by the way that
you have like a a demo to go along with
it because i think it it makes
it makes it more accessible and uh it
demonstrates also the the capabilities
of this it's almost like we're moving
into
it it's it's we're moving into the world
that
gpt-3 maybe has created for text uh with
these
image language models
because you know we got the same feeling
from gpt3 oh no you can i can just go
and i can put any text right and i can
interact with the system in a sort of a
free-form way and uh it's really cool to
see that we're also moving in this
direction with with the image models um
in in terms of in terms of just the the
process of how this is research went
about it you ended up with a cool system
with a nice way of bootstrapping data
and so on uh was there can you maybe
tell us a little bit about stuff that
didn't necessarily work out during the
research was there any point where you
were
maybe disheartened a little bit things
that didn't work out
what were your low and your high points
during
this
the creation of this paper
yeah uh
actually one of the like the
examiner we had was when we first tried
to scale up the petrina with small web
images
using this line data set that we have
downloaded which takes quite some time
it doesn't help that much
so then
it feels really feel like why scaling up
the data is not beneficial in the model
so then i did some more analysis and
after
that i realized that a lot of those
images are
very very small in the resolution
some are just icons or some brand names
uh
and if i remove those then it begins to
show the the gains
but i think that that's one of the kind
of the blockers we faced
and i think after
we first get the bootstrapping
especially the nuclear sampling uh to
give a big
performance gain then at that point we
are quite confident that
this should be a good solution
and i think that that point is when i
realized okay this method
should work well and we can write a
paper about it
good don't do you want to say something
yeah i believe some of these strategies
they also arise from the discus internal
discussions with other group members and
salesforce so it's really a lot of
cloud intelligence behind the scenes so
yeah that's
how is how is the research
uh organized at salesforce like i have a
bit of insight into you know the let's
say the the big tech giants like google
and facebook and so on and they
they have they have their research
divisions uh at a company like
salesforce who who is more
customer
i want to say customer or all these
companies are customer oriented
obviously but um
how is how is research organized there
like what do you do while the model is
pre-training for a week like do you have
do you have other stuff to do or are you
mainly researchers or what's life like
there
yeah so first of all i would say that ai
is a big part of salesforce what they
try to achieve like to use ai to better
help the customers so we have this
separate research division
maybe not as large as google or facebook
but i think everything works quite quite
well in our research team and in terms
of our day-to-day operation
uh i think it's mostly similar to other
industrial researchers we
we can
quite flexible to to
research or do some more product
oriented work
and
like we are motivated to do research
that can generate high impact uh that
can really change the field
in a more substantial way and while we
wait for the gpu to finish training you
already will just do other research
stuff or
read some papers involving some
internal discussions or maybe try to
solve some
real production problems
cool
is there anything else you want to get
out about this paper you already said
people can go to to the web to your repo
and you have a you have a demo also
available
is there anything you'd want to get out
like how can how how is what's the
easiest for people to get started with
this research
yes so i think uh first let's uh again
welcome to try out our demo and welcome
to visit our github we do have
i think quite detailed instructions on
how to download and portray or find you
on the model
and also i welcome any suggestions or
questions you might have
about our
model that
we can use that to improve
our
model
or the code uh that would be great
cool
anything any last messages
yeah our team is expanding so if you are
interested just let
yeah yeah we are looking for uh interim
position in the vision language research
cool who can apply anyone that is at
university or
yeah anyone comply we hire globally so
we can do remote working now
cool excellent
okay uh dongxi and jindan thank you very
much for being here this was a lot of
fun
thank you for having us thank you really
appreciate
[Music]
you